so some viewers of this channel often
ask us why with a channel called
visualpolitik we make videos about
companies for example we've already
talked about amazon inditex and tesla
among many others well we do this for
two fundamental reasons now the first
one is that we see politics in a broad
sense and this means that we can't talk
about politics without considering
economic and social issues of course i
don't think we can deny the huge
influence that big companies
play on our lives today
secondly we know that many of you love
these kinds of videos so we keep making
them and you know well we like these
kind of videos too so
here we are so in this video we're gonna
have a pretty interesting combination
we've got the company of bmw
and the countries of germany and china
as we mentioned here at visualpolitik
germany is the mother factory of the
world it's the place where machines and
the things that go
into the other things that other
countries produce are manufactured
and of course of all of the industries
the automobile industry is without a
doubt the most famous
and also the most peculiar we all know
that brands like mercedes bmw volkswagen
porsche opal and audi are all german
and this is because germany isn't only
one of the largest car producers in the
world it is also considered the cradle
of the first car yes you
heard that right
in 1885 a german engineer called carl
benz
tried to place a combustion engine into
a three-wheeled chariot
this was known as the bend patent motor
wagon and it was able to reach an
astounding speed of
16 kilometers an hour
in total 25 units were manufactured and
in one of them bertha ben's carl's wife
made what is considered the
first car trip in history for a distance
of actually 94 kilometers which isn't
bad now there's something you might be
thinking about right now and that's that
well back then there were no petrol
stations
so how exactly did bertha benz refuel
well she did this by buying a petroleum
derivative
in pharmacies called ether that's right
we could say that pharmacies were the
first gas stations in history but
of course that's not the reason why cars
in germany are quite so
important
you see because more machines are always
needed the automotive industry viewer is
one of the most productive
and most capitalized so well what better
place to manufacture them than germany
the country of machines however despite
all of this let's just say that in
recent times the german automotive
industry
and the european automotive industry in
general hasn't been the most popular one
in danger of extinction
in recent times there has been a
widespread feeling that the traditional
automotive industry and especially as we
said european manufacturers will be the
big
losers of the upcoming electric car and
autonomous car revolution
because who would want one of those old
companies when we have fresh innovative
companies like tesla
now this is something we've actually
talked about on this channel not so long
ago despite never having made any money
and producing very few cars tesla has a
market value that is as
large as that of bmw and which is far
superior to companies such as renault or
peugeot
so how is this all possible
well as we saw basically because many
investors consider that in a few years
tesla will literally take over the
market and here the viewer
is where questions begin to arise will
the electric car transition really be
that quick
are european manufacturers too late to
join this revolution
well i don't know what you think but
some information at least
does not seem to support these ideas
according to a recent study from the ifo
institute europe owns almost half of all
patents
related to the electric car leading the
world ranking and being well ahead of
countries such as japan
23 percent and the united states 18
yvonne martin president and chief
investment officer
of magayanes value investors
well for now let's assume that elon musk
is right and tesla manages to overcome
all of the problems that currently
affect it for example the production of
the model 3
and thus fulfills his most ambitious
forecasts managing to sell 2 million
cars
in 2022 this means that he would have to
multiply his production capacity not by
2 or by
5 but by 20 in just over 4 years
well in that same year at least 110
million vehicles are expected to be
produced in the world
honestly when we consider the strong
growth of the middle class in emerging
markets i would actually bet on a far
greater vehicle production than that but
let's just be prudent
and stick with that number out of those
110 million cars no more than 20
are expected to be electric cars or even
just plug-in hybrids
so what exactly does that mean well what
it means is in the best case
scenario tesla would have a market share
in the industry of less than two percent
and
nine percent in the electric car market
in other words we could say that the
cards that not even dealt yet and that
even if tesla's best forecasts are met
there will still be
many companies in the market companies
such as bmw
bmw is one of the great icons in german
industry robust luxurious and
technologically advanced cars
who doesn't want to bmw
see in nine of the past 10 years this
brand has been
the world leader in premium cars and the
truth is that this is pretty interesting
see this company besides owning bmw also
owns mini and
rolls-royce and at the time of
publishing this video has a market value
that is very similar to that of tesla at
about 50 billion
despite this both companies have many
many differences
while in 2016 elon musk's company
managed to sell 76 000 cars while losing
770 million the german company sold 2.36
million cars and had a profit
after tax of more than 7 billion
alright so now i know what many of you
are probably thinking wait a minute
simon this
isn't a fair competition tesla is
currently investing in research and
they're developing new technologies
while bmw makes the same cars they've
been making forever
well it isn't actually quite like that
let me explain
in 2016 for example the german group
invested more than 5 billion
in research and development meanwhile
tesla's investment was five times
smaller at slightly less than one
billion dollars
and of course a lot of that bmw
investment money is going to developing
electric and autonomous models
bmw to spend 237 million dollars on
battery cell center and that's not all
okay so here's a question for you and
please do not google it and cheat which
company bmw or tesla do you think is
going to sell
more electric cars in 2017
now many of you are probably betting on
tesla right now
by a lot right well
wait just a second because the truth is
that taking both electric cars and
plug-in hybrids into account
both companies are actually very close
now it does look like tesla
is going to win this race with a few
weeks left in 2017
but it's seriously close in fact both
companies are expected to close 2017
sales with approximately a
hundred thousand electric cars sold yes
okay so i'm sure some of you are going
to argue that tesla has stored a lot of
its model 3 cars which
in principle translates into sales for
the next few years
the model 3 will be new territory for
ceo elon musk
and tesla as a company the sedan has
already received at least four hundred
thousand pre-orders
that is true but the german brand also
hopes to improve its numbers
in short as we always say here at
visualpolitik the future
is by definition uncertain tesla could
be a great company but it's not going to
be the only one the truth is that by
selling almost as many electric cars as
tesla by investing five times more in r
d and by earning a cumulative profit of
more than 30 billion dollars in the last
five years
i think we can say that bmw is at least
a very
important competitor
in fact it is surprising that both
companies market value is practically
the same considering that expectations
for one are so much higher
than they are for the other this is
especially when we consider that in
recent years bmw has become
a major and very important player in the
chinese market
the great chinese market
since 2007 and despite the international
economic crisis the bmw group has
managed in less than 10
years to increase the number of cars
it's making from 1.5 million in 2007 to
2.37 million in 2016.
and of course that translates into more
income and
also more benefits
see bmw's net benefit that is the money
that's left for the company after taxes
has more than
doubled in this period of time check out
this graph
looking at that graph we could say that
things have gone rather well for the
company
well one of the pieces that has greatly
aided this progress
is actually china take a look at how
their market has evolved
in 2016 it managed to sell half a
million cars out of which
300 000 were manufactured in china
itself
through a partnership with the local
company and two hundred thousand were
imported
mostly from factories that the company
has in germany
in other words one out of every four
cars sold by the bmw
group is already in china a market where
the automobile sector will surge in the
upcoming years along with its middle
class
well the fact is that beyond any
comparison with tesla bmw's chinese
adventure
shows us a couple of things the first is
that far from what is usually said
china could be a great source of
opportunities and wealth something which
incidentally we've been mentioning on
visualpolitik for quite a long time
each year 80 million chinese people join
the middle class and this
has very clear and obvious consequences
on their ability to spend
secondly it is very common to hear
politicians of all backgrounds arguing
that in order to export more the
currency
needs to be devalued well germany in
fact they say quite the opposite what is
required isn't a cheap currency
it's competitiveness and good products
but that is something we are going to
talk about another time and now it's
your turn
if you had to choose which company would
you bet on would it be tesla or would it
be bmw
at the end of the day as we've seen both
have a very similar market value
so please do leave your answer in the
comments section below as well as
in this survey and i really hope you
enjoyed that video please hit that like
button if you did and do not forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos every monday and thursday and
also check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always
thank you for watching
you